today I'm going to talk about the hidden
source of anemia both B12 and iron
anemia that you probably have never
heard before and this involves a microbe
called H pylori and each pylori is a
fascinating bacteria that the majority
of the population have already in their
stomach and when the timing in the
environment is just right it can come
out of remission and create all sorts of
problems primarily with gastritis
inflammation of the stomach
ulcers as well as atrophy of your
stomach so the stomach starts shrinking
out of all the places to exist why would
you want to live in an acid stomach
right and also it actually eats iron
right that's one of the things it eats
now typically what causes this microbe
to come out of remission and create
problems is when the stomach pH
oses the acidity okay so the more
alkaline your stomach becomes the more
that that microbe can survive and
potentially come out of remission when
the pH becomes more alkaline as well as
in individuals that are susceptible like
their immune system is weaker as a
survival mechanism it also has a enzyme
called
urease which basically causes the
breakdown of urea and then that turns
into ammonia
now this is a survival mechanism because
ammonia is that it's extremely alkaline
it has a pH of like 11. I mean think
about this we have the stomach which has
a pH between 1.5 to 3 which is like
battery acid so you have a pH of 11 for
ammonia it's super alkaline and that
allows this microbe to exist and Thrive
now there's also another component
molecular mimicry okay what is that that
is another survival mechanism where that
microbe can mimic your own stomach cells
and so it's trying to go underneath the
radar and for the most part your immune
system is tricked by that but not a
hundred percent a lot of times there's
an immune reaction okay and then what
that immune reaction does is it starts
attacking your own stomach cells
as well as something called the
intrinsic factor and both of those
situations lead you to a very severe B12
deficiency
and then when the stomach atrophies
because of this microbe now you're going
to get what's called pernicious anemia
which is a B12 condition in the first
phase when you have gastritis you have a
lot of inflammation and you have a lot
more acid and that quickly decreases as
there's more and more damage to the
stomach and you start having atrophy and
you lose the function of these little
gastric cells and then the stomach
becomes more alkaline so you start off
being too acid and then it goes over
here to alkaline okay and that's just a
survival mechanism and when your stomach
is not alkaline now we lose the ability
to absorb iron we can't activate iron
that's inactive to the active form we
can't absorb iron so now we become iron
deficient so we have both an iron
deficiency and the B12 deficiency not a
good situation
so here you are taking all this iron
taking all this B12 and wondering why
it's not working you're trying to fix
this thing but there's something else
going on completely underneath it and of
course once you're diagnosed with H
pylori the treatment is at least two
months of antibiotics okay usually
multiple antibiotics and the real
unfortunate problem with that is that a
lot of people end up with antibiotic
resistance to this H pylori microbe so
now
the antibiotics won't work anymore okay
because the microbes quickly counter
that mechanism so here you are two
months of therapy right you have all
these side effects of the condition as
well as all the side effects from the
antibiotic in your gut and other places
this is why the treatment for H pylori
with antibiotics is uh it's not very
successful long term because they're not
looking down the road of what's really
happening they're thinking that this
microbe is the problem and so they just
need to wipe it out and then the problem
solved when in fact it's just the tip of
the iceberg there's a lot more to do
with the pH of your stomach the strength
of your immune system which now you just
weaken because of the antibiotics now we
still have gastritis we might have
ulcers we have atrophy of the stomach
we also now can't protect ourselves
against microbes that are coming in from
our food so now we have an increased
tendency to get infections to the body
viruses bacteria fungal You Name It We
also can't absorb minerals too well we
also can't break down protein too well
so you can see this problem goes from
bad to worse what could we do about this
I would recommend taking something that
is more of a natural antibiotic that is
not as potent you have to take it longer
but there's minimal side effects okay
and one of the best things they've
researched on this is sulforaphane which
is interesting because it's not really a
plant it's a chemical in a plant it's in
broccoli Sprouts sauerkraut it's in the
cruciferous vegetables so sulforaphane
is a compound is a potent anti-microbial
and the extra cool thing about this is
this it can work against antibiotic
resistant microorganisms and infections
okay so if you have this antibiotic
resist instant microbe well sulforaphane
can actually still work on that whereas
a antibiotic won't work on that so we're
taking a natural remedy not as potent
but we're taking it longer to make sure
that we do this without the side effects
so that's step one you may also want to
add another natural antibiotic called
wormwood okay wormwood extract and you
don't have to take much you just take a
small amount over a long period of time
and I'm talking about three to four
months now you can get yourself
aerophane from a supplement or I would
recommend better yet get it from
microgreens or Sprouts broccoli Sprouts
or broccoli micro greens right and have
a little bit of that every day in your
salad that's what I would recommend the
next thing I'm going to recommend as a
solution is zinc there's many different
forms of zinc you can take but it's more
important to just get zinc than to focus
on what type of form of Zinc but zinc
can be very effective against
ulcers
gastritis as well as healing the stomach
and helping you build up your
hydrochloric acid and so once the
gastritis settled down and the ulcer is
healed then we want to add betaine
hydrochloride or apple cider vinegar to
your stomach but not until the ulcer is
gone and the inflammation is gone the
other thing that you want to do that can
greatly help
put things back in the balance is to
either take a really good probiotic or
better yet start consuming a little
sauerkraut or even some pickles there
are certain microbes in sauerkraut and
pickles that are very beneficial to help
counter this H pylori because remember
we have the good bacteria and the bad
bacteria right so we want to increase
the good from this probiotic or the
sauerkraut and help counter the
situation and plus sauerkraut also has
sulforaphane and it's really good for
the digestion if someone has gastritis
or for that matter any digestive issues
all right so now that you know this
other source of anemia which is very
valuable if you have anemia probably
important to show you the other causes
of anemia okay and I put that up right
here check out the video